[Music]
and no way home grossed an incredible
1.9 billion dollars at the global box
office and ranks among the best mcu
films ever among fans and critics very
soon sony could even reach the 2 billion
us dollar mark an extended version will
be released in theaters as has been
known for a short time it is called the
more fun stuff version and is expected
to contain some bonus scenes that were
not shown in the previous theatrical
version sony now communicated the
official release date via the official
twitter channel of no way home thus the
us cinema release is scheduled for
september 1st 2022 a similar approach
was taken with avengers endgame where a
longer version was also released in
theaters a few months after the actual
theatrical release are you going to
watch the movie again as an extended cut
or are you reluctant to support disney's
practice do not hesitate to tell us in
the comments down below
a couple of weeks ago we got some
initial information about the upcoming
the hunger games the ballad of songbirds
and snakes the movie adaptation is set
up as a prequel and thus tells the
backstory of the hunger games films with
jennifer lawrence we will see 21 year
old golden globes winner rachel zegler
in the starring role she plays district
12 tribute lucy gray bear and her mentor
is none other than corey lana snow who
is already well known as the dictatorial
president from the previous movies in
the prequel he is still an adolescent
but already determined to lead his
tribute to victory in the 10th hunger
games as deadline now reports there will
be a new cast member who is not unknown
in the fantasy genre the talk is of
peter dinklage who became famous for the
role of tyrion lannister in game of
thrones rumor has it that he will take
on the role of kaska highbottom who is
the dean of the academy he therefore
plays a key role in the prequel since as
the dean he wields an immense amount of
power and is clearly superior to corey
elena snow in terms of hierarchy we
believe dinklage is definitely capable
of playing this role after all he has
already proven in game of thrones that
he knows exactly how to play cunning
powerful men we are eagerly awaiting his
appearance though an official
confirmation is still pending francis
lawrence who is already known as the
director of the previous films will
direct the ballad of songbirds and
snakes the screenplay was written by toy
story 3 author michael arndt hunger
games veteran nina jacobson as well as
suzanne collins the author of the book
series who work as producers
nevertheless there is still more than a
year to go before the movie hits
theaters as it is scheduled for release
on november 17 2023
just recently we reported that the
pre-production of dune part 2 has been
running since the beginning of the month
as the responsible parties announced
last monday via twitter the real
shooting with the actors has now begun
among the cast of the sequel are of
course timothy chalamet as paula tritus
and zendaya in her growing role as chani
as well as black widow actress florence
pugh as princess erilan there are
already first unofficial set photos of
pew which show her in a princess gown in
addition to the three young actors the
cast includes christopher walken as
emperor chatham iv stellen skarsgard is
baron harkonnen javier bardem is stilgar
and rebecca ferguson is lady jessica a
brand new addition to the cast by the
way is suhaila yakub who joined just a
few days ago and plays the freeman
leader shashakli the plot picks up
directly where the previous movie left
off the focus is this primarily on paul
and chani who must reunite against their
opponents behind the camera of dune 2
everything remains the same since
director denis villeneuve has put
together exactly the same team as for
the six-time oscar-winning predecessor
this means that at least on the
technical side nothing should go awry we
are very excited about dune part 2 and
look forward to its theatrical release
on november 17 2023
wolverine is one of hugh jackman's most
successful movies and also one of the
most popular marvel characters of the
last decade jackman made his last
appearance as wolverine in logan in 2017
and since then it has been uncertain
what the future of the character will be
a new casting has been under discussion
for a number of weeks now and will
probably involve rocketman actor taran
egerton in an interview with the new
york times egerton confirmed that he is
currently in negotiations with marvel
and kevin feig and then he himself is
hoping for the opportunity to play
wolverine he also had some words to
share about hugh jackman he was
concerned he might not be able to keep
up with jackman who gave the character
of wolverine a great amount of
recognition the agreement between
eggerton and marvel is therefore not a
done deal as he himself emphasized in a
recent conversation with andy cohen
there eggerton attempted to somewhat
qualify his statements from the past as
nothing has been decided yet however if
egerton were to be cast as the new
wolverine he would certainly not think
twice about accepting the offer what are
your thoughts on the casting would it
work for the kingsman actor to take over
the role of wolverine or would you
prefer somebody else to play the part
let us know in the comments
the planned the boy spin-off has been
the talk of the town for a few weeks now
after the launch of the long waited
third season it is all the more fitting
that the official title of the upcoming
series has now been revealed the
spin-off will be called gen v whereas
previously everything pointed to the
title varsity generation v refers to the
drug compound v which lends the
superheroes their powers as you can tell
from the synopsis gen v is taking place
at vaude international's superhero
college which is the only one of its
kind in the us moreover the series is
said to be r-rated and will test the
physical sexual and moral limits of the
college soups together they are to
compete for the best deals in the top
cities the r rating in particular is
great news as it also puts the spin-off
on par with the main series which
likewise received the infamous r rating
on the other hand it would also be
rather reckless if they were to dial it
down a notch in terms of violence and
humor after all that's exactly what
makes the boys stand out a further clue
from those responsible also gives a
direct idea of the direction in which
gen v is heading for the atmosphere
supposed to be like a hybrid of the
hunger games and a college series in the
course of the series we can also hope
for a meeting of the college soups with
the superheroes from the main series the
crossover was recently confirmed by
producer eric kripke in an interview
with deadline so far the young actors
patrick schwarzenegger marco pogozi liz
broadway and london thor have joined the
cast to name a few we are definitely
interested in the new series and look
forward to more information about gen v
the competition in the streaming
business is extremely tough and so the
respective providers must always try to
surpass others while amazon has had a
respectable streaming catalog for a long
time the visual presentation has clearly
been lacking no matter if via tablet
computer or gaming console the overview
was always amazon's biggest drawback
compared to disney plus or netflix after
many years the people in charge seem to
have finally realized this as has now
been announced the interface will be
completely revamped the horizontal menu
at the top of the screen will now move
to the left side just as we are used to
from other providers in addition the
thumbnails will be given more space
there will be more preview images and a
blue check mark will make it easier to
see which content is available for free
and which ones are subject to a fee
there are many more features that will
be released gradually on smart tvs
android and fire tvs in the coming weeks
all other devices will receive the
update at a later date unfortunately it
remains to be seen how good the update
really is at the end of the day and
whether they managed to redesign the
confusing layout satisfactorily
we have known about disney's upcoming
lilo and stitch film remake since 2018
however not a lot has happened in the
past four years this might now gradually
change because as coming soon reports a
director has meanwhile been found the
talk is of newcomer dean fleisher camp
who receives some critical acclaim with
the bizarre film marcel the shell with
shoes on he thus takes over from crazy
rich asians director john m chu who was
originally in talks to direct the movie
the scriptwriter is not officially known
yet but disney is set to be in final
talks with chris kt bright who is part
of the extended crew of 2016's moana
apart from that however he is still
quite a dark horse in hollywood the
original movie of the same name lilo and
stitch dates back to 2002 and was a huge
hit for disney at the time the story
revolves around a lonely hawaiian girl
named lilo who happens to encounter the
aggressive little creature stitch one
day stitch escaped from a cruel
experiment on the planet turo and soon
wins lilo's heart at the same time
however she is unaware of stitch's
destructive powers disney has not yet
given a release date for the remake but
we will keep you up to date
that was our news for this week feel
free to watch our new original on
transformers rise of the beasts on our
channel where we give you an exciting
overview of the next installment of one
of your favorite franchises also the new
trailer for halloween ends was recently
released and you should definitely check
it out
[Music]